un enfant que vous connaissez pas c'est
bob dylan
alors ce qu'un animateur télé vous
l'aimez bien aimé ce prix il vous plait
gérard si vous trouvez vous tuez les
gardes en chine je vois cette lame donc
comment il s'appelle cyril féraud
quand on pense à cyril féraud si c'est
cyril féraud et bien vous participerez
haslam ils feront ainsi un record absolu
voilà ce dossier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous vous remettez bull a mentionné la
télé vous avec nous on va vous installez
c'est vrai vrai jeu mais on va faire un
slam avec plaisir et même sur ma
tablette
salut les copains moi je suis très
mauvais la la la la vitesse non mais
alors est ce qu est ce que vous vous le
prendre dans un an cela vous passiez y
avait évidemment mais on va même faire
un slam spéciales ainsi enfin gérard
mais on va trouver un cadeau que nous on
adore et or est ce qu'on fait un slam
spécial gérant genou mais je te jure
qu'on fait c'est gérard jugnot et ses
amis et c'est pour la promo du film même
s'il faut pour le prochain film pour une
association aba les abus
le fait pour l'homme pour le rire
médecin allez on le fait on a une pour
le rire médecin est basse et les enfants
c'est sûr et certain regard original mix
étaient belles surprises comme à l aller